Let's now hear from the most important people
as far as The David Pakman Show is concerned,
it's the viewers, it's the listeners, it's the
trolls and the haters and all of those people
we use. This scored for our new phone system.
You can join at David Pakman dot com slash
discord. Let's start today with CODI from San
Diego. Codi, you are on the air. What is going on?
Cody, please, on mute yourself, we don't want to
start on such a sour note, you were on the air,
Cody from San Diego. And the last
opportunity for Cody from San Diego.
That's too bad, that's not an auspicious start, I
have to tell you. Let's go next to Tamika from New
York to Moesha from New York. Please save us.
Hi. Hi, how are you?
I'm good, how are you doing? Well.
So first of all, I want to say I like
your livestream today talking about women
as a working mother, it was really good.
They know that they're actually talking
about it and thinking about it. Right.
But my gripe today is with black
conservatives. OK. Not necessarily, it
fits with all conservatives, but Candice Owen has
been in the scene lately talking and she just says
things about people of color that just don't make
sense to me. I'm mixed. So she says things that
she sees herself like. She represents
herself. And, oh, my experience is this.
So this means that that's the experience for
everyone. And I wholly disagree with her that
you can't base your experience on what affects
other people or what happens to other people.
Yeah, you don't make policy around
anecdotes. You make policy around statistics.
Exactly like she said about Meghan Markle,
that she can't possibly have experienced
racism or colorism because she never experienced
it herself, because she was she's married to a
British guy and she never experienced herself.
So how can so she thinks Meghan Markle's lying.
Candice Selwyn's is married to a British guy,
you're saying? Yes. Oh, I didn't know that
that's funny. I mean, it isn't Candace, didn't
Candace Owens grow up like in a privileged
Connecticut suburb or something like that? I
don't know much about her, but it seems like
I mean, whatever her experiences may be
relevant to her. But as you're pointing out,
it doesn't mean it's relevant to anybody else.
Exactly. I've seen her on video saying,
well, I grew up poor, but I overcame I
worked hard. I got where I needed to be.
Oh, OK. Maybe she did. Maybe she did. I mean,
I don't I don't know her story. It's just sort
of like who cares what her story is, you know?
Exactly. It's like I grew up not privileged,
but I grew up OK. And I do attribute the fact that
I do have certain privileges that other people I'm
a lighter skinned biracial person, so I definitely
know I have privileges that maybe a darker skinned
black person would not. Right. So but that doesn't
mean that I can't understand that other people
have experiences that I may not experience. Yeah.
I mean, to me, it would be sort of like if I said,
hey, listen, I am a Hispanic, me David Pakman.
I'm a Hispanic immigrant from Argentina. I came
to the US, I wasn't discriminated against and
everything's fine. So clearly there's no problem
here. And it's like, well, hold on a second,
I, I'm white, Hispanic and I learned English
young enough where you can't tell when you hear
me speak that I'm an immigrant, it's like, well
imagine if I applied my experience and said,
this is how we should think about Hispanic
immigration. It would be it would be ridiculous.
Exactly. And I see that happening so much on the
right. But they apply their own experience to
the rest of the world. I can't talk. I'm from
New York. I can't talk about what happens
in Middle America. They their experience is
not going to be the same as my experience.
Right. Right, and it just frustrates me.
Yeah, well, you know, this this is on both
sides with the right. You have these right wing,
like social conservatives who are homophobic for
their whole lives and then suddenly, like their
kid or their nephew is gay or something. And
they have like an awakening where they can't
imagine what it's like. They can't empathize.
And then also you have what you're describing,
which is they believe that their situation
is everyone's situation. It's yeah,
it's the inability to think abstractly. It's
only concrete thinking that they're able to do.
Exactly. I was told by somebody on social
media that I went to high school with that
I'm privileged. How can I talk about this? And
I'm like, I'm not talking about necessarily
myself. I'm talking about us as human people.
Right. Right to Moesha, beautiful phone call,
I really appreciate it. Thank you. All
right, there's Tamika from New York.